a big warm welcome to the launch of icc  tv and it's going to be hot hot hot in  the city this winter our consultation  caravan will be traveling everywhere to  hear your point of view on council  issues the hollywood film pete's dragon  will be attracting 250  filmmakers to our city from weta  workshops and walt disney the iconic  oyster festival at bluff will be on the  23rd of may but on this occasion they  will have their own purpose-built venue  commemorating world war one will be the  play on shawnick bear by morris shadbolt  as well as the opening of an exhibition  at the southland museum and art gallery  and as for rugby park well when we  finally get ownership of it we'll have  an open day and a free event to go with  it and finally we have made it with our  international airport yes a charter  flight will be going to the melbourne  cup so tune in to icc tv for further  information